hey guys so i didn't show you that much
last week because i was ill in bed for
the entire week
so uh let's get on and show you all the
interesting stuff that i got up to
uh i i just went to the library let's be
honest here
so uh this week yeah basically i lost a
lot of time last week uh because of
illness
and i needed to catch up on work so i
basically worked
from the point where i was able to get
out of bed until the hand in
pretty much non-stop in the library uh
it wasn't
terribly much fun i must be honest but
um
you know it's not like i'm i'm honor
bound to do this work but basically i
only have three tutorials
or three classes per topic
this term so if i want to get the most
out of that if i want to get the most
out of the tours i need to be able to
at least have attempted the questions
when i get there and have reviewed the
material and be able to understand the
discussion that goes on
um it's to my benefit to do the work
basically so that's why i really pushed
it this week
all nighter supplies we meet again
incidentally next level
all night attackers store your energy
drinks on the window ledge of the
library that way when you need them
they are chilled the more you know so
this week
in terms of the work that i've been
doing uh in theoretical physics i've
been looking
at uh the group theory and lia algebra
content
and uh classical field theory so uh the
main
thrust of the whole course i guess you
could say it's field theory uh and we're
doing the all the classical fairy tale
theory stuff now
we're gonna be moving on to the quantum
field theory stuff um
i think possibly the start next time i
think we might just be getting onto it
the end of this term but that was the
theory and in the atmos
uh we finally moved on to the
geophysical fluid dynamics uh
at last because i was getting a bit
bored of doing cloud microphysics i'm
not gonna lie
i i love the entire course like it's
incredibly interesting but
i find it difficult to get excited about
cloud formation um
i'm much more interested in the flower
dynamic side of things which is really
why i took the course
uh and the more microscopic aspects of
climate so
looking at gravitational waves in the
atmosphere and stuff like that so i
finally get
my hands on the meaty material which i'm
happy about as you might know there are
eight weeks in an oxford term
so the last hand at the end of seventh
week means that once you've had the
classes in eighth week
yeah you've got vacation work to get
going on but really you can have a
couple of days just to enjoy yourself in
oxford without doing tremendous amounts
of work
so this weekend in particular um
is christmas themed because in oxford we
celebrate christmas very very early in
fact today the 25th of november is known
as
oxmas uh where's my hat merry oxmus
everyone so uh in the university we
celebrate uh we'd like to be able to
celebrate christmas
whilst in term time uh and
so kind of by extension the town gets
into christmas a bit earlier so
this earlier this week we had the
switching onto the the lights in town
and i was like a carnival that kind of
accompanied that and i'm gonna
and in some pieces we had uh
our hog roast so every year the jcr
um funds a hog roast that
immediately follows the carroll service
in the chapel so
that involves getting the j-cell
christmas applied and setting up the
christmas tree getting decorations up
sorting out the catering
and just sort of running the whole event
and it's a really really nice thing to
do
in seventh week um it happens today so
on optimus
and um it's just a chance to get to the
christmas spirit early you know we had
like we had christmas music on
everyone seemed to be really enjoying
themselves so it was really really fun
evening i was the guy walking around
with just loads and loads of mince pies
and just being able to offer people free
food is one of the best things in the
world you instantly become a million
times more popular
in other news we also had the um meeting
this week for the jcr pantomime
so another christmas tradition or oxmoor
tradition
in saint peter's is to do a jcr panto
um i filmed one before i've never been
in one before and this year i've been
written
in uh i'll be filming it again this year
so most likely a sniffer or that i'll be
finding what's going through this vlog
but that's
going to be fun
if probably a bit embarrassing i'm
almost certainly going to get custard
pie
like i think everybody in the cast is
going to get custard pied that seems to
be another
oxman's tradition but beyond that just
because i've
been spending the library i haven't had
the chance to cover all of that much i
mean i've missed everything this week i
dropped
my meditation class my band rehearsal uh
physics society talk i just i just
dropped everything in order to
to concentrate on the work uh which has
paid off
you know like i understand it a lot
better now but it it just means there's
not that much to talk about in these
vlogs
next week on the other hand uh eighth
week which is the last vlog in this
series and i haven't quite decided what
i'm going to do once this series
finishes
if you have suggestions about that put
that in the comments section
um next week is going to be really busy
because not only have we got the jcr
panto we've got my concert which is
happening on monday night
i've got a friend's concert to go to
i've got a friend's panto to go to
i've got meetings um about
using youtube in oxford access which is
quite exciting
i just have my masters collection uh
there's a whole wrath of the next week's
video it's probably gonna be quite long
to compensate for this
this week's video and the previous
week's video being quite short
but yeah a lot happening last week a lot
happened this week
it's just that i wasn't involved in it
really
hopefully that's enough material for you
guys this week i promise next week would
actually be quite an exciting
episode i need to stop calling them
episodes hopefully next week could be
quite an exciting vlog to finish on and
as always
if you oh yeah if you still have
comments um so if you have questions
that you'd like to ask about
interviews i'll be doing my uh q a on
interview stuff
next week um i will be answering as many
as i can of the questions that were
posed in last week's comic section if
you have anything else that you'd like
to ask please
by all means put them in the comments on
this video incidentally if you're still
waiting for a reply from me about a
message that you sent me
uh i will be getting on that i'm sorry
i've been a bit lazy well not lazy i've
just been a bit busy
uh this week uh but with work and
everything so i will be replying to you
might take a couple of days but
be patient i will get around to you so
yeah that's it for this week uh
i really look forward to doing next
week's video because it should be quite
a fun one
um there's going to be a lot to say
oxford at christmas is one of the
surprises like i didn't know
that oxmas was a thing really um
i suppose when i was back in school i
only ever thought of christmas has been
like a family thing whereas the chance
to actually spend christmas exclusively
with your friends
um especially in a place that's as kind
of magical as oxford is
it's really quite something i really
like oxmoors i really like christmas
anyway i'll see you guys next week
thanks for sticking around